foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
yeah
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
and always leads Banks of Russia
rash out Russia no collusion no
obstruction no collusion no obstruction
hell boy we find out that uh
some trumped up former FBI official
has hired
in his indictment
of laundering money
for darpaska the Russian oligarch the
billionaire
apparently
after uh he was his money was sanctioned
by the United States of America
foreign
giuliani's Old Law Firm is now going to
represent him in that indictment
I can't make this [__] up you can't you
won't you won't you will not be able to
find a better dumpster reality TV
fire
than the ones surrounding Donald Trump
you won't I mean this morning Grandpa
poopy pants the Cheeto does queuing on
her is again giving away the game
on true social
of the crimes that he committed in
Georgia
as we prepare to possibly
see the grand jury
um that will present evidence to another
grand jury
what the the collecting of the testimony
that they got
from several people that they had to
compel including
Ruby Giuliani by the way
and Rudy Giuliani really has taken a
back seat
in the entire Trump story and the reason
why is because
Trump didn't pay him
and Rudy Giuliani is no longer an
attorney
so what the [__] he gonna do
what what is his lies gonna mean
I mean all the attorneys
that have lost their law license
have been tossed aside because they
can't really do anything for him
besides talk well he can talk
he can yell and scream
they're the ones that have to sue people
uh Alina Haba gonna be the next one on
the chopping block
my guess is
with this million dollar fines there's
probably going to be more fines
and sanctions against her and her long
form
for the Tish James
lawsuit that they walked away from
but this is the never-ending story of
the corruption of trump
we [__] told you this [__] back in
2016 the email lady was right on every
point
every [__] point and speaking of the
email lady entering the chat here on
this story
of this former FBI official what's his
name
mcgoogle my goggle magogical I don't
know I don't I don't [__] know does
it really matter
what these characters names are
in this Saga of absolute the real deep
State corruption in this country think
about this this [__] was ahead
of counterintelligence
Comey months before the election
puts him in charge
over the Hillary email thing
now is Comey the enemy here I mean other
than his own unwitting stupid stupidity
to think
that fascist in this country
are going to do what's good for our
constitution not for their little
fascist beliefs
I mean he's he's probably a hundred
percent guilty of that [__]
but this FBI agent
foreign
was assigned to enforce the sanctions on
their posca when he retires in 2018 he
works for him getting paid tens of
thousands of dollars per month he joked
With Friends
get this you're I I bet oh man you're
gonna you're gonna recognize this when
you hear it
you're gonna recognize this when you
hear it when I tell you how he referred
to the person he was working for the big
guy
where have you heard that before where
the [__] have you heard the big guy I'm
working for the big guy
where have you heard that in some laptop
conspiracy thumb went somewhere
listen folks
if you have not been paying attention
to our political body
for any certain number of time and I'm
talking really you should have been
paying attention for about the last 15
years
not the last three not since 2016.
really since about 2008.
when Barack Obama was elected president
of the United States for the first time
if you have not been paying attention
since then
you probably do not see what is coming
but it is written all over the wall here
Donald Trump will be the Republican
party's nominee for president of the
United States Ron DeSantis is making big
moves to try to be the head fashion but
I don't think he's going to get there I
don't think he's going to get there I'm
going to talk about Ron DeSantis today
that [__] scumbag that racist bigoted
piece of [__] [__] that God damn
[__] Floridian Nazi
we're gonna talk about him Banning
[__]
teachers private libraries in their
classrooms that [__] piece of garbage
will get there trust me we'll get there
Ron DeSantis I is trying to make a play
here he he's someone pointed out is when
is he going to grow the little
uh mustache this morning
and they commented on Twitter maybe I'll
find it here in a bit
but that's the only thing that little
that little Nazis
is lacking down in Florida
I told you they're banning Book Fairs
they're banning certain books it's not
gonna stop there they are not gonna quit
they're not gonna stop at at
centralizing your children they're not
gonna stop they won't they're Nazis
their ideology their ideology Ron
desantis's ideology Trump's ideology
these [__] Republicans in the House
of Representatives their ideology
murdered six million Jews in the
Holocaust
and they put Nick Fuentes back on
Twitter today speaking of Nazis
anyways I digress
Ron DeSantis I do not believe
is going to muster up enough courage to
challenge Trump in this election
when he is indicted Donald Trump that is
I mean Ron DeSantis probably you know
corruption runs deep and they're all the
same so you know who knows maybe we'll
get lucky
when Trump is indicted on charges
for January 6
for the the really honestly the
financial fraud after the January uh
after the 2020 election
and his lead up to January 6 where he
was grifting his supporters and piling
the money in his own [__] pockets
that's really where I think they're
going to capture him
and the documents case where he's
covering up evidence he stole our
documents took him down to Mar-A-Lago
destroy him whatever he did with him
that documents out of those empty
[__] folders that he that he
destroyed are buried with his ex-wife
who knows where the [__] they are to
cover up his coup attempt those charges
when he's indicted on him bet Bottom
Dollar that it will only unite the Nazis
it will only unite the right wing
crazies
it will only re unite the Q Anon nut
jobs in this country to circle the
wagons around the Cheeto dust Cuban
honor around Grandpa poopy pants their
orange mango Mussolini Jesus you better
damn well guarantee it
I'm telling you right now that is what
is going to happen
how in the [__] can't you see this Kevin
McCarthy for an entire week took 15
votes
15 votes
to get to be speaker and he genuflected
day after day minute after minute to to
Donald Trump and his [__] moglodytes
in the House of Representatives
the people who helped him attempt a coup
Matt Getz Perry Biggs gozar
the likes of them go on and on and on
deep inside our government they are the
Deep state
if you've been paying attention to
American politics the last 15 years
and don't understand
why Donald Trump is going to be the
nominee next year
you haven't been paying enough attention
he will be the Republican nominee
and indicting him is only
going to raise his status
it will only make it more likely that he
will be the nominee not less
David they've ignored
every single fact
of Donald Trump and their and and his
deep State corruption up to this point
their projection projection
their hypocrisy they've ignored it not
only ignored it they willfully welcome
it
and you think
you think that this party isn't going to
nominate him
even under criminal indictment that's
actually his plan folks to avoid a trial
in 2024. that's right next year Donald
Trump's plan to avoid a trial not
indictment a trial
is to be the Republican nominee
and a federal judge is going to Grant
him that wish he will not go on trial in
2024 he won't
but he will be with the American public
he will be with us on trial
and we all get to be jury members
in 2024 every last [__] one of us
and not only that we can make sure we
sign up more jury members in 2024
and that's the battle that must be
fought that is the that is the Target
that we must hit
because we cannot prevent these [__]
America First Nazis
nominating the Cheeto dust q and honor
as their [__] Jesus we cannot stop
them from doing that we won't
don't even try it's not worth it
the only thing we can do is use our
voice and use our narrative and our
messaging
to make sure the country knows that hey
you know that thing that you voted
against in 2020 because it was a threat
you know that thing that you got out and
worked your ass off to make sure there
was no Red Wave even though they
gerrymandered the [__] out of our
country and out of your votes
and they barely won the House of
Representatives losing the Senate one
more vote
you know that thing that you were so you
needed to make sure you protected your
democracy and your way of life for yeah
it's gonna be even more in 2024.
and it starts right now why do you think
so many Democrats are hopping in these
Senate races right now
yeah the senate race in California at
the senate race in Arizona the senate
race in Missouri Democrats are jumping
into that primary now right now because
this election cycle has started whether
you like it or not
foreign
that's why these these Maga trolls
have absolutely
magnet like magnets to the Biden
document story they're gonna regret it
and I've got a clip of uh don Jr
uh Mr bunny ears himself someone someone
quote tweeted
the video I posted says uh Little Bunny
Foo Foo walking through
watch it oh my God I got maybe I'll do
that this afternoon if
if you just watch it on silent and just
sing the song it really looks like
that's what he's doing
I don't know
um
oh boy oh boy oh boy but we're gonna
show a video of Don Jr totally walking
into a trappy with his documents thing
Lindsey Graham even sang this morning on
the record hey uh I know Joe Biden for a
long time and there's no way there's no
way in hell there's anything to this
documents case and that is a good signal
and from even from Lindsey Graham
Lindsey Graham loves to play politics
with things but he is not going to touch
that with a 10-foot pole because he
knows listen Lindsey Graham knows that
there's nothing there with the Biden
documents thing
and if you don't know that by now well
you don't know the media very well the
media is trying to make a huge drama out
of this try to be like well what's the
difference what's the difference between
the Trump documents and the bite listen
they should not ask that question that's
a dumb [__] question you know the
answer to the question
foreign
why is Trump's intent to steal documents
from the government of the United States
to hide something and then he obstructed
to cover it up and he's still
obstructing why why
that should be the question
the Biden team the Biden Administration
Biden's attorneys
are cooperating to unprecedented
levels they let the Department of
Justice they welcomed them to come
search
they didn't need no [__] judge
to issue a search warrant because there
was criminal activity they said yeah
come on down there's no criminal
activity come and look again if you're
not if you're not committing crime
you're not scared for someone to come
look at your [__]
and if you're out there thinking that
the Biden thing the Biden documents is
going to be bad
for biting imagine if that's true if
that's true and you're not understanding
in the political body with the messaging
and the narrative that you can create
and help push
out there in this country that's right
you you are responsible for this it is
us we are the government we are the
electorate we are the ones who vote we
are the ones who get other people to
vote and we influence them that is right
that's how that's how politics and
elections work that's how it works you
got to convince people of ideas
of narratives
a messaging yeah you got it you gotta do
it
how the [__] you think politics works
but it's up to us
to make sure that everyone knows the
truth and the truth is that Donald Trump
stole our top secret documents to cover
up his attempt of a coup and cover his
crimes and his collusion with Russia and
no telling up what other crimes he stole
those documents to cover up and to sell
to make money
because it's always a [__] grift with
this piece of [__]
there's no way in hell not a [__]
chance in hell hell will freeze over
before I ever believe
that Joe Biden took documents
intentionally to cover up a coup attempt
so stop listening to the media on this
story and let them fall into the Trap
too
let them fall into the Trap they're
setting it for themselves
and only for themselves
don't listen to their narrative don't
listen to the rights narrative
go with the truth and the truth is
that that they're not the same they're
not even on the same planet
not close and all you have to do
is look at the Deep State Corruption of
Donald Trump
and his cohorts
one of which is this case
of this former FBI official
who is in charge of counterintelligence
and was in charge
of making sure Dara posca followed the
sanctions after his retirement 2018
not only
did he support Aeropostale
but he received payments
through shell corporations from
darapaska in tens of thousands of
dollars per month
and he this guy has got the Clinton
email stench all over his sticky little
fingers
and the first people he turns to
and his legal defense is Rudy giuliani's
Old Law Firm hmm
nothing suspicious about that at all not
at all
the while again I'm going to show this
today uh again we we don't show
statements from Donald Trump unless we
think that they have significance but I
think his statements this morning have a
lot of significance and he's telling on
himself again as he always does
in this Georgia uh election intimidation
scheme where he was trying to get uh the
Secretary of State current and at the
time raptisberger to just find some
votes
just find me the votes just make it up a
mattress somewhere
maybe maybe you find him in the trash
can
hmm who knows
who knows
foreign
but again if you've been paying
attention
the last 15 years to American politics
you will understand where this is headed
and if you know where it's going which
I'm pretty sure
I've been paying attention for the last
you know I don't know 20 years to
American politics
a little longer
but the last 15 years has told the story
well
and the the Republican dumpster fire
reality TV show on the right
is headed for their their grandiose
season finale here
and boy is it gonna be a doozy
and I can only guess what will happen
but you
you the American people
the pro-democracy Coalition determine
the outcome that's right it's you
you're the ones
it's all in your power all in your hands
you did it in 2020 you did it again in
and liberalism will be strong
and fight back in 2024. I'm sure of it
and I'm here for it every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific on YouTube Twitter and
twitch for two full hours and
simulcasting from the Midas touch
Facebook page we're trying to get to 20
000 on YouTube so don't forget to
subscribe if you're on a different
platform please come over and subscribe
I've got a nice ask for you if you will
for me
get three of your friends
maybe your Maga friends maybe some more
liberal friends hell invite anyone you
want over to watch the show if they're
interested in politics I know they'll
find something to take away from it
whether they love me or hate me or love
to hate me either way I'm okay with it
just share it for me get them to
subscribe also don't forget to follow us
on Twitter at Tony Michaels pod and
download every single episode on Apple
Spotify and Google and if you're on my
just touch Facebook page or on Facebook
at all if you still do that over there
follow us at Tony V Tony Michaels on
Facebook and also why not follow us on
Twitch I know twitch is kind of what is
Twitch go check it out download the app
it's free and I get paid for you to
download the app but go over and follow
us on Twitch as well and you notice you
notice that yesterday this patreon uh
thing showed up support Tony on patreon
I reopened my patreon so if you'd like
to um uh help me out or or support the
show and support me in the content that
that we create here uh it always is uh
great to have that and we got three well
there's four different levels
and there's four different levels over
on patreon five ten to twenty dollars
and then there's a fifty thousand dollar
level on patreon now don't freak out
don't freak out but
um
one level over on patreon if someone
pays me fifty thousand dollars I'll shut
up for a whole month shut up for a whole
month I doubt they're gonna do they're
not gonna pay you 50 anything they'll
pay me fifty thousand dollars to shut up
I highly doubt it that they will do that
but hey why not
it's a great joke go over go over to uh
patreon.com uh Slash the Tony Michaels
or just go to the tonymichaels.com click
the patreon link at the very top of the
page and you can go see the 50 000 shut
me up uh level while you're there check
out the other the other levels as well I
think we might uh do some
some special content over on patreon too
I'm I'm coming up with trying to come up
with some ideas of exactly what we'll do
with that I I don't like to have a
social media and ignore it I haven't
Mastered on now and I I post some stuff
over there but I kind of ignored it and
I I don't like to ignore social media
because I feel like if you're on there
and you're following me you need to get
something
um so go check out patreon tell me what
you think comment to me message me DM me
if you can uh just simply tag me on uh
Twitter if you want and say what you
think or Facebook tell me all kinds of
crazy [__] if you want tell me how much
you love it how much you hate it all
right also I want to tell you it's
Tuesday and usually on Tuesday we have
Texas Ball but Texas Paul is still on
vacation
he's still on vacation
so wish uh Texas Paul if you're on his
social media wish him a happy vacation I
think he might be back next week or the
week after I'm not real sure I'm gonna
have to check with him uh to be sure on
that but Texas Paul will be joining us
uh in the next few weeks when he when he
comes off his time off which he's well
deserved well deserved I don't know if
you've been watching his social media
but uh sending pictures from the beach
and stuff so um Texas Paul if you're if
you're out there sleeping on the beach
listening uh thanks thanks for taking a
vacation and we welcome you back uh soon
my friend and everyone here at the Tony
Michaels podcast loves
loves Tuesday with Texas fall so you'll
have to stay tuned in for the next
couple weeks again I I can't remember if
it's next week or the week after that
he's back but he'll be he'll be back
very soon on Tuesdays don't worry don't
worry no feuding going on with me in
Texas Paul not at all actually maybe we
should start like a rumor huh maybe
that'll help
I don't know
that um you know there's a feud between
me and then we'll we'll make up the next
I'm just kidding there's no Feud no Feud
he's just on vacation everyone stick
around we'll be right back right after
this break
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the show
what you guys took patreon thing
seriously
thank you so much
here's a shout out
category on patreon it's the it's the
higher of the three real levels I mean I
don't know I think I would I if someone
paid me 50 Grand I would take a month's
vacation don't you think that would be
all right
I mean depending on when they did it you
know what I mean like I may have to take
that sumbitch down next year before the
election because we're gonna have to
work hard so I can't be I can't be
taking money and not pushing the
messaging that's worth more than fifty
thousand dollars I'm sure I'm sure of it
well no one's willing to pay for it no
one my nearest thing here's the thing so
maybe I'll take that down or pause it
next year so we don't get in a situation
where uh some person's paying me all
kinds of money and some right wingers
pay me all kinds of money to shut up and
I shut up and I want to do that but
wouldn't you think it would be worth it
I don't know I think it's worth it
that's what I thought I thought well
that's a good number
fifty thousand dollars to shut me up
yeah why not and that's just a month
that's not for all time that's just one
month and I just take a month off you
know I'd go down to the beach like uh
Texas Paul did now I'd have enough money
then to go down to the beach for a
couple days I don't know I'm just saying
everyone deserves a vacation every once
in a while
but but the real the real tears that the
actual deers uh on patreon there's a 5
10 and 20. the five is you're you're a
member of the [__] fam and I know
your honorary member of the [__] fam
here but it just shows your support
that's five dollars and then the ten
dollars you actually get a promo code
for the merch store and then the twenty
dollars you're gonna get the the same
thing you get in the other categories
but you also get a shout out and I'm
considering doing some exclusive content
over there nothing big not a not a whole
show maybe I don't know what we're gonna
do maybe some short videos or something
maybe some different conversations uh
in-depth uh kind of I don't know I don't
know what we'll do we're just trying to
come up with some ideas for some content
over there just for patreon
but uh you're gonna get a shout out I'm
not sure exactly how I'm gonna do that
yet I think what we'll do is maybe we'll
do a monthly uh shout out but the
problem is is if we get a lot of people
signing up I may have to just do a
weekly shout out where we do a shout out
every week
um and I might just do it as a separate
video and put it up on there first on
patreon and then post it on YouTube uh
for the shout outs and maybe we'll do
some other stuff uh during the shout out
little thing man so I'll give you a
shout out somehow
um either on Twitter or something
something I'll give you guys a shout out
if you if you go on there because I
appreciate all your support you are the
best audience in the world I truly do
mean that now you guys come here every
day this audience has grown huge someone
pointed out the other day to me they
sent me a message and said you know what
when when because they promote the show
everything they say you know what
when you started there was like 11
people watching this thing 11 11 11 11
people watching this thing there's
there's 11 people the minute I put out
the link now
there's there's dozens of people looking
for the link because I don't always get
it up at the exact same time
so you are the best audience in the
world and we're growing rapidly and it's
because of you it's because of you
you're spreading the word you're
watching you're feeding those algorithms
so I appreciate all your support and
everyone who's who's already went to the
patreon even though yesterday I really
didn't say anything uh the mods were
posting a link in the chat and we had it
up on the screen but I I didn't really
say anything
um so I appreciate all the support that
you guys give rather it's just sharing
the link and having people in the chat
or or or going and supporting us uh
either through the tip jar on the Tony
michaels.com or signing up each month
for patreon
she can do either one of those just go
to the Tony michaels.com you can either
get to the tip chart there's the merch
stores there's the the the official
merch store there's the hat store if you
want to [__] them hat and right right
here there's the [__] hat everybody
knows when I wear the [__] hat
there's the store there with the hats
and there's Gabe Sanchez store don't
forget to go to Gabe Sanchez's merch
store and look at his merch over there
too my great co-host and executive
producer now Gabe Sanchez so we we
really do appreciate all your support
here on the show it's very difficult to
do this show two hours a day every
weekday and the reason why is because
it's not just two hours I mean there's
pre-prep there's post prep that we have
to do and we want to do some new things
we want to come into this new election
cycle swinging hard swinging hard
because boy do we have a lot of
right-wing nut jobs that we have to
knock down
and get out of our way so democracy can
win and liberalism
small l
you [__] hate Watchers liberalism can
flourish freedom I don't know if you've
looked up the word liberal
anytime in the last I don't know Century
but you should look up the word liberal
you should go look it up see what it
means and then decide if you are against
Freedom or you're for it I don't know
maybe a good idea might might but you
know might be a good idea to know what
words mean
I mean in Florida they don't want you to
know what words mean so much so that
they really don't even want children to
learn how to read anymore I mean
honestly Rhonda Santos is in a situation
where he has to make sure the people in
his State don't even know how to read he
is raising his own Hitler Youth that
have no clue how to read
and the reason why is because if you
read you might educate yourself and if
you educate yourself you might know that
Ron DeSantis is a [__] Nazi and
that's he's going to be in the [__] list
Roundup where we round up all the Tweety
tweets and trendy trends so let's start
the countdown
[Music]
[Applause]
the [__] list
welcome back to the Johnny Michaels
podcast you have reached the part of the
show where we round up all the Tweety
tweets and trendy Trends I believe Gabe
Sanchez is going to join us in a minute
but
boy
you know sunlight is the best
disinfectant that's the way that we look
at it here and Ron DeSantis is
disinfecting himself
by making it very well known
that he in fact
is a God damn fascist
and he wants to be the Hitler of Florida
look I don't know if you read your
history books out there you moglodytes
apparently you don't want to know how to
read Because you elect people who don't
want to teach your children how to read
so
let me educate you a bit on what group
of people in our in our world's history
decided it was a good idea to ban books
and ban libraries because they didn't
want people to know the [__] truth
let me give you a hint
it was 1920s 30s and 40s in Germany
there was this dude who murdered
six million Jewish people in the
Holocaust I don't know if you know where
I'm going with this it might be obvious
to some of you that have a [__] brain
it's the Nazis
it's Hitler you [__] boneheads
uh Stephen King I think has a great
tweet and I I don't know if it's New or
Old
um
doesn't matter you know it always will
be relevant
if the powers that be and it goes
something like this here I should try to
find it to to quote him exactly but if
the powers that be are trying to ban
books
from your schools
you find that book you go to a library
wherever you can go to find that book
and read what they don't want you to
read
listen
folks
he's Banning AP
African-American studies
in high schools for 17 and 18 year olds
and the reason why is because Rhonda
santis a white dude doesn't think that
black people want AP African-Americans
I'm not [__] you
I'm gonna show you a [__] clip where
this white man
this fascist white man is telling black
people what they do and don't want
look after after Nazi Germany in 1930s
in the 1940s
when uh the real American antifa
American soldiers went over and smashed
up Nazi Germany
with the help of Russian soldiers
and our allies in Britain and the UK
after we smash them up
over here
we had our own form of fascism and it
still lives in the institution today
and Ron DeSantis
the governor of the state where goes to
die
is deciding and telling black people
what they do and don't want Gabe Sanchez
have you seen this clip of him saying
this [__] yeah oh my God you know
there's the one and let me Aaron rupar
has it let me just bring it up here [__]
it what is what is bring it up um he's
got a thread here now this is the first
video and he talks about queer Theory
that's the reason why he wants to ban
the AP African-American studies right
and really these [__] boneheads do
this [__] where they're acting like
little children or learning these things
and it's not that's not at all it's like
the CRT [__] that they went on and
on and on and on about and they still go
on and on about they don't know what
[__] CRT is they don't know what
critical race theory is they don't know
that it's a goddamn Law class for a
[__] law student the same way that AP
African-American history class do you
know what the AP stands for on
know what the AP stands for advanced
placement oh do you mean do you think
they would teach advanced placement to
[__] first first graders Gabe Sanchez
yes advanced placement I do yeah [__] it
dude why not why wouldn't you believe
that this is a college score an A A
prepped College course
I want to know why queer theory is is so
tied in with the African-American go
ahead
so if people don't know this
um well Republicans wouldn't I mean
because they don't want to know but yeah
anyone who uh
you know here's a little here's a little
free AP African-American history lesson
for you okay you have to sign up for it
or anything I'm not sure okay good so um
there was a a trans activist Marsha P
Johnson okay in the 60s and 70s in in
New York City wait a who a what
a trans activist what does that mean
exactly well it's an outspoken advocate
for gay rights okay Mark
so you're saying that that that the
lgbtq community just didn't pop up out
of nowhere no no oh no I thought I you
if you if you talked to these these uh
people who hate wokism you would think
and wokers US mother wokers you would
think that this lgbtq community just
just started a couple years ago but what
you're saying is you would think what
you're saying is is that is that the
lgbtq community has been around for a
long time is what you're saying it's
almost like it's almost like
oh my God people within that Community
even before they identified with that
Community have been around since the
beginning of [__] times that is kind
of weird it's crazy so this activist so
this activist tell us what the how it's
tied to the queer sorry I didn't mean to
get it I just want to make sure yeah on
a level footing here right right so the
reason and this kind of irked me when I
saw that that clip this morning I was
like ah this is [__] son of a [__]
all right so Marsha P Johnson an
outspoken advocate for gay rights trans
activist
um
very pivotal in the Stonewall riots okay
and I just want people to know you know
for any white people out there that the
reason that gay rights were able to get
pushed to a point to where they are and
get the momentum is because
of black gay trans activists in the
community being the actual heroes in the
sense of pushing forward policies and
rights for their own Community it's
almost like activists who fight for
equality and Equity do it like across
the board or something right almost like
that almost it's almost like that's been
around as long as the lgbtq community
it's almost like these it's just weird
it's just weird it's almost like hey if
uh if I don't you know I should make
sure as a person that I have rights and
that my fellow human has rights right
and you want oh that's kind of a wild
idea it's crazy I mean it's easy it's
not quite crazy yeah right
but what I what I will say is when I
watched that clip this morning I was
kind of pissed off because I was like
the idea that
it either he doesn't know right he
doesn't
and it's the most ignorant response well
he's a queer rights what the folk the
queer rights have to do with the AP
African-American we already teach
African-American studies shut the [__]
up you bigoted [__] [__] what
we have here is actual history advanced
placement again you have to typically AP
classes unless you're some like
Prodigy you don't take AP classes until
you're in your junior or senior year
which means you're 17 or 18 year old
yeah 11. I mean these are these are
these are people that are too old that
Matt gatz wouldn't even wouldn't even
get right they're on they're they're
waffling the age right and then they
they kind of spoil in their age you know
they're waiting for Matt gants even I
mean these are the idea the idea and I'm
sure and I'm sure we'll see a lot more
people uh online today be like you know
this is this is [__] absurd because
not only is it taught to students who
are in high school because again you
know you can't take an AP course when
you're in [__] kindergarten right
don't you think though that that
um
the AP part because so many times we
want to get down to language and words
and really AP and advanced placement
does it really tell the average person
why can't we just call it CP College
Prep why can't we do that type of stuff
why why do we have to in this country
and and it's really stupid and and I'm
blaming the left really is what I'm
doing here I'm going to attack the left
a little bit here is that you want to be
so [__] correct about something that
you can't just say what the [__] it is
right you can't just say what the [__]
it is that's how the left got so tangled
up in the CRT [__] right in the Virginia
Governor's race in 2019 they got so
[__] tangled up in that goddamn mess
because they can't just say you can't
you can't just say it we we do not have
to be afraid of words we do not have to
be afraid of people getting offended if
people want to get offended they should
get offended that is their right to be
offended be offended cope but be
offended but let literally here we have
we have the the fact that he can
actually just brush this aside as if
this is not number one a college prep
course and number two not part of
History because I want to go back to
something that you said
about the activism in New York um
uh we talked about it on this show
before that the massacre in Oklahoma
um of a black community I had no idea
that even happened because I'm white and
I grew up in White America I wasn't
taught that wasn't going to be taught
that they were they weren't ever going
to say that [__] out loud right just
like they didn't say they did they don't
say anything about the Stonewall riots
never heard about it until I was an
adult yeah well into my adult years
never [__] heard about it won't hear
about it wouldn't hear about it and
these these These are young adults who
were gonna go to college who were gonna
get educated who we are going to be
reliant on to lead our country into the
future need to know this history and
queer Theory like you're saying the
Stonewall riots that didn't just have to
do with the LGBT community but all the
the margin Alliance communities banding
together because they are marginalized
to work for equality and Equity somehow
isn't part of AP Africa in American
Theory which again it should be College
Prep right not Advanced and like when I
you know when I was in high school uh
they also
offered so they were like you can take
this AP course
whether you want to test
and and you want to take the actual AP
exam right to to get the placement so
that you can get the college credit
right because that's technically it's
like a dual credit you get your high
school credit and then you also get a
college credit because I took AP math
classes right right so some places don't
do that so typically they'll be like
they'll be like all right you're taking
AP course it counts as your three
credits or whatever it is and then when
you take the AP exam you have to test
either pass fail in this because you
know it's like oh we only accept scores
are four or five out of five to get
credit for the college to accept it and
then you don't have to take that course
which means you save money right it's
all an investment crazy education is
investment for a long-term goal right
get out of here is that why it costs
money insane
but some some high schools like my high
school they we had a community college
nearby and we had a we had a A Train
That's how you get your dual credit and
so you didn't even take the exam you
already got the college right that's
what they did that's what our they did
in our case there was a college that
sponsored the class right right I would
take and I don't remember there was a
couple math classes that I took with
that were College Prep or AP as they
call them but they're college prep and I
was getting dual credit for taking that
that college course quote unquote right
in high school now
having said that I want everyone to
understand that and I don't know the
numbers here but I don't have to know
the numbers to know that this is going
to affect very few people in Florida
yeah and what I mean by that is it's
going to affect very few people in
Florida who qualify for these courses
who can take these courses who can
afford to take these courses because
they generally cost money if you're
going to get dual credit and I don't
know the case here but I would bet I
would almost bet gave Sanchez that the
majority of the people that are going to
take this course are marginalized groups
of people who who are probably going to
be lucky to afford College in the first
place and they're going to be able to
take these courses at a discount and get
college credit but now they won't and
it's probably a very small number of
students this is not a forced curriculum
he is acting as if they are pressing
this curriculum on students that is this
is an elective course this is
all good goes back to the idea that no
one is forcing you to do anything no
one's forcing you to get the vaccine
well well Rhonda Santos is forcing a lot
of people to do a lot of [__] and right
forcing people not to do a lot of [__] I
mean that's the person who's forcing but
again you know you're not forced to take
this course right uh you it well now
you're forced that you have to take
another course because you can't take
this course because it's not available
ban someone and be like you know what
the rest of the country
can take this AP course and get credit
for it but you people of Florida don't
get to get that per you don't have you
don't you don't get you don't deserve
that privilege right I'm gonna Shield
you from the Reverse Racism that is this
AP American history course and it's not
even it's again again they always want
to paint this up is is something that
it's not and we're going to get into
because I'm not going to lay off
DeSantis today for a while I mean we're
almost to the top of the hour and I'm
gonna keep going after this son of a
[__] this [__] I I just I'm so
[__] pissed off at this APM
African-American uh history class thing
but but it I've been telling people
since last [__] summer that these
[__] were gonna do this when they
started talking about banning books and
Book Fairs and taking this this
curriculum out of this book at a map
because there was the letter CRT in it
that they're gonna take your [__]
libraries away they're gonna take your
[__] books away they don't want your
kids to learn how to read and there's a
story and we'll go over here after I get
done with these clips of Rhonda santis
answering questions from the media about
this college prep African-American
history class
um that he's trying to cut out of very
few of Floridians availability but it's
you know it's the same you know I mean
obviously you know it'll be effective I
would imagine unless unless let's say
the
uh there are unless there are
organizations that Sue the State of
Florida for Banning access to education
in this way and also take a lawsuit
against the the Board of Education
um or the Department of Education under
under
um DeSantis now I don't know how long
that would take in terms of actually
getting a decision but
um maybe they try to stall them and say
there's no way or no reason why you
would be able to under any Merit of law
that you should be able to ban
accessibility in the same way that
people want to ban books and all that
[__] like I saw a tweet from Stephen
King he's like look if anyone's trying
to ban your books you should go into the
library go to the store and try to
figure out exactly why they want to ban
can you try to find that tweet I want to
show that tweet because I brought it up
in the first 30 minutes
um now here is Aaron Rupert which we
rely on thank you very much Aaron for
for posting Clips he's one of the ones
we rely on for Clips here to get out in
the open
um but he says the DeSantis is asked
during the news conference about the
state's rejection of an AP again College
Prep African-American history class he
says this course on black history what's
one of the lessons about queer Theory
that's the wrong side of the line for
Florida standards
um uh and he fails to forget that the
the citizens of Florida should make that
choice not him I want to point something
out here that's significant too
the reason why he's able to do this now
again he's gaslighting the [__] out of
everyone look at the just look at the
[__] the placard on his thing on
education State the education state
anyone who lives in Florida I'm not
trying to bash you but Florida the
education state right yeah well
um and it's always projection so it's
the exact opposite here he's trying to
do away with education not promote it
um anyone who's again like Stephen
King's is trying to get you to not read
something you need to go read that [__]
now there's something that they're they
don't want you to know about them uh is
the main key point is they don't want
you to know about them
um
but I do want to point something out
that Ron DeSantis is attacking this
college prep course in high schools and
the reason why is because he can at this
point right but do not put it past him
to start attacking this course in
Florida universities right so not only
not only is Ron DeSantis going to have
his all-out attack on public schools
because he thinks he can convince people
that this class has taught to first
graders guarantam T that's what some of
these boneheads believe at this point
that they're teaching are going to teach
my first grader queer Theory and about
African America I mean that's what
that's the whole goal right right in a
classroom for I mean like look man we
got [__] bins in the alphabet on the
[__] ceiling now I'm not saying that
maybe there are places in Florida where
Ron DeSantis you know maybe he's taking
you know what maybe maybe Ron DeSantis
is taking like uh A continuing education
course right now it really has to bring
it down to the fundamentals to learn at
a first grade level but the idea idea
that he's there any or I mean well not
first credit maybe this is second grade
I'm trying to think like multiplication
second grade maybe but the idea that
that's addition isn't it
well you know you know what's funny
about this uh here down here you see
this Shelf with books in it that's no
longer allowed you cannot have a a
classroom library in Florida anymore so
this here so expect him to burn those
later yeah well I think that's probably
why he's there is to burn these books
yeah yeah that's probably I mean and he
decided to have a press conference and
Gaslight everyone right that Florida is
the education state but again he's he he
he has the ability as the governor to
really stymie and stop uh the truth from
coming out to these very few students
who are even going to be elected to take
this course and actually get this course
um this college prep course for
African-American studies in the first
place but he's using it as a wedge just
like they use the trans children as a
wedge people who have gender disorder
which is very few very few in the grand
scheme of things they use very few
children to leverage their [__] hate
and to press their hate on on every
single child that there is
um in the same way that they're banning
books we were in uh you remember when we
were in that Twitter space and it was a
couple of months ago with these [__]
right-wing idiots and like very obsessed
with them we're not Banning books we're
not Banning books that's not what we're
doing we're just we're trying to make
sure that that children don't see we're
we're we're censoring make sure and I'm
like look you're running down a road
where you're gonna ban entire libraries
and right once you ban this then you ban
that right lo and behold here they are
now Banning [__] classroom libraries
in Florida with felony charges by the
way if you do not comply I wonder what
those little [__] in that little
Twitter space would say to me now when I
I told you this would happen I told you
this would happen they were like oh so
you were prefer for Adventures of
Huckleberry Finn being banned I said no
no I'm not for The Adventures of
Huckleberry Finn should be on the
shelves people should read that book
right um but let's watch this first clip
here
um because it is disgusting when he
talks about the queer Theory because
he's obviously being overtly bigoted
towards the lgbtq community but the
second clip I think is the actual one
that is aimed at black folks and the
black community and he's gaslighting the
[__] out of him and he's he's doing the
whole
uh segregation then segregation now
segregation forever and what black folks
want uh well I'll show you both Clips
but let's watch this one
studies course that was rejected by the
state and a lot of criticism of that
move uh people saying you know this is
exactly what we're appearing with the
individual Freedom bill I don't know if
you or the commissioner could maybe
expand a little bit more about sure I
mean I think so
um you know as you know uh in the State
of Florida our education standards not
only don't prevent but they require
teaching black history all the important
things that's part of our Core
Curriculum this was a separate course on
top of that for advanced placement
credit and the issue is we have
guidelines and standards in Florida we
want education not indoctrination if you
fall on the side of indoctrination we're
going to decline if it's education then
we will do this course so when I heard
it didn't meet the standards I figured
yeah they may be doing it's way more
than that this course on black history
what are one what's one of the lessons
about
queer Theory now who would say that an
important part of black history is queer
theory that is somebody pushing an
agenda on our kids and so because Ron
DeSantis would never push an agenda on
children
placement again this is a course that
goes through a separate organization
okay
where they make books and study guides
and reviews and manuals on how to
[__] teach and learn the topics of
the course that will be put on the
[__] exam okay so the idea that this
is indoctrination is [__] [__]
all right just know it's not real it's
not indoctrination the idea that Ron
DeSantis wants to create a Cova denying
science lacking uh uh whitewashing state
that is indoctrination the idea that he
wants to segregate and push and say the
history of this group
that has been
years of trauma and pain and and stigma
by another group of people
is something we don't want to teach we
don't want to teach them their own
history and the thing is a lot of these
you know
some things they may uh they may not
know and they learn about in class and
other things they have to learn through
family members and their own culture
right but then they have to realize that
oh our culture my history isn't
important enough for the State of
Florida to teach to my other friends
right my other classmates because
through education and knowledge sharing
God forbid we become a better society
and we learn from our mistakes so that
we don't repeat them but Ron DeSantis
gets out of state out of mind I know it
was bad and that's why I don't want
people to learn about it because if
people know what really happened then
they'll say oh [__] white people have a
really bad history of doing [__] to
marginalized communities and we can't
let people know that and that's what Ron
DeSantis is right now A triggered
whitewashing bigot who is afraid of
other people knowing the truth about how
this country was created and founded and
stolen and and people were taken
advantage of he doesn't want people to
know that and that is why he's trying to
restrict
students
in high school
from learning about that right because
in some of this some of these topics are
sensitive and some of these topics
you're like ah you might want to be
older to actually go through the the
insanity and and and to potentially
triggering uh or or uh you know kind of
like warning label like this is this was
intense this is really bad but we got to
talk about it let me tell you the
community that that he's also because
it's he in this second clip I'll I'll
point it out um
what he's saying but he's not just he's
not just trying to convince white people
that they shouldn't have guilt he's
trying to convince the black community
that they shouldn't learn their own
history that's what he's really trying
to do because he doesn't he doesn't
definitely does not want white children
to know this history but he sure as hell
does not want black children to know
this history and that is the most
important point he does not want black
children to know this history but let's
let's finish this up and I'll get to the
next clip which I think is if you can
imagine even more [__] disgusting
than this one so when you look to see
they have stuff about intersectionality
abolishing prisons that's a political
agenda and so we're on that's the wrong
side of the line for Florida standards
we believe in teaching kids uh facts and
how to think but we don't believe they
should have an agenda imposed on them
when you try to use black history to
shoehorn in queer Theory uh you are
clearly trying to use that for political
purposes
the gay
the guy who who literally who literally
is strong arming the education system
yeah in Florida for his own political
purposes he's like yeah you're you're
just using this course for political
purposes right what the [__] the idea
also the idea that they said and uh let
me just get the the exact quote here
right the idea that they said the course
is inexplicably contrary to Florida law
and significantly lacks educational
value
lacks significantly lacks educational
translation Ron DeSantis doesn't want
people knowing the real history of how
white people [__] over the
African-American Community for hundreds
of years right and once they got their
rights he doesn't want them to know
exactly how they went about it and you
know again whether he knows and probably
doesn't know the actual history of
certain groups especially uh those in
the trans and gay rights activist groups
that were pushing for certain rights
within the African-American Community he
goes
yeah don't need to I don't need to share
that information I don't need to make
sure that because again it all comes
back to if we know our history right
then we can prevent repeating those same
mistakes because if you if you make the
same mistakes then you're in this you're
in this uh Silo of you know of insanity
which is like you know you're you're
doing the same thing expecting different
different results that's why when you
have a diverse and I'm sorry to blow
people's minds here but when you have a
diverse team or a board of directors or
execs
that come from different
uh demographics uh uh different
socioeconomic backgrounds whatever it
may be different type experiences all
together you wonder you realize that you
can make better informed decisions
because everyone has a I've got insight
into this and I've got insight into that
instead of it being a boardroom of white
dudes thinking ah this is the way it's
going to be and that is the way that Ron
DeSantis runs his team if you think like
me
then that's how it works if you look
like me great if you don't look like me
but you think like me then that's
awesome but I'm going to use you as a
token to say I'm not racist because I've
got this one guy like the guy who from
his uh
uh the guy who's in charge of his his
health department Health Minister his
health Minister who went you know went
to school at Stanford out here on the
West Coast but had some pretty
um regressive and dumb ideas and takes
on science and then said oh there's no
science behind any of the coveted
vaccines and social distancing and any
of the protocols we have because that's
just a [__] devil
and so if you think like him great if
you look like him even better if you
don't look like him but you think like
him that's fine too he'll just use you
as a prop well let me show you this clip
because I believe this clip tells that
story all too well where he's trying to
not just convince white parents and
white children
that they shouldn't know
black history in this country that that
oh it's there's no black history there's
no white history there's only American
history right because he's not I'm
telling you in this clip
Rhonda santis is running against a wall
here where he's found that white
Liberals are not going to put up with
them and marginalizing any more
communities and and what he's trying to
do is convince the black community in
Florida that they are not anywhere in
shape nor form tied to the lgbtq margin
Alliance Community has nothing to do
with it you're two separate communities
he's dividing them
and he's trying to convince
black folks that they do not need to
learn their history they just need to
learn their Amer be good be good black
folks and learn American history not
African American history okay that's
what he's doing I'm telling you well
he's also saying learn American history
and I mean I you know obviously you can
argue and say that uh Africa like
American history is African-American
history absolutely in that it is so
intertwined but to go through and
nitpick all of the events and say ah
okay I want you to learn Africa or I
want you to learn American history
caveat uh it doesn't include any of the
African-American history that's in there
right and then you're like oh look at
these white people they came over so
nice in Columbus yeah and they did this
in the pilgrims and and the [__]
Quakers and they did this and they sat
with the Native Americans and they
totally didn't [__] commit genocide
well I I mean there there's there is a
huge history in our country of
oppressing Irish folks yeah I mean
there's a history you can go look at it
you can go you can go Italians Irish
polish Mexicans black like all of these
all of these groups marginalized at one
point well because at some point there's
always with these [__] there's always
an other right right always another and
all they need and and this is how
history goes right you get one group
Irish comes over you've got Italians
that come over they're not allowed but
however they look like you right right
it's a lot easier lighters it's a lot
easier but then what happens is then you
get brought into the the white fold
let's say
and as long as you're not the target of
the attacks and you then look at someone
else and go oh you you illegal you do
this you're bad person you you know you
criminal whatever because of the way
they look let's say it's Italians that
come over and they're darker skinned
they're you know Irish are are much more
white than Italians let's say so then
boom the stigma is yeah we're both not
from this country
but you don't look like me I look like
them so I'm with this group even though
they kind of already hate me do you know
that's why they're less do you know why
there's that's not why there's white
white history that's that's why well
also because they just steal everything
well right well right they steal all
culture and assimilate all [__] but
anyways let's let's get back to the
Rhonda Sanchez clip here because I think
this clip what he says in this clip is
way more Despicable and way more
Sinister and it goes to the heart of
what he is trying to do when he's
gaslighting here
um just with his simple sign Florida the
indoctrinations I mean the education
State excuse me I misread it
um people in Florida would too because
they're not going to be able to read
soon because they won't let them read
but let's listen to how Rhonda santis
thinks black people what they he's gonna
tell them what they want here in this
clip
AP studies that divorce Parts have been
listed as concerning is the topic of
movement for black lives can you
describe what about that is concerning
that some people is that what the
abolishing prisons is that part of the
so if you read actually what's in there
they're advocating things like
abolishing prisons now now that's a
that's a radical political position
you're free to take that in your own
life I don't think very many people
would think that that would actually
work
um but how is that being taught as fact
to be able uh to do that and I also
think it's not fair to say that somehow
abolishing prisons is somehow linked to
like black experience and that's what
black people want I don't think that's
true at all I think they want Law and
Order just like anybody else wants Law
and Order so now Ron DeSantis is telling
black people what they want
um I think this is the most disgusting
[__] thing in this entire press
conference that this [__] said right
was was that that the idea because in
the in the curriculum the idea of
abolishing Prisons is what is being
taught because there is an idea out
there to abolish prisons and the reason
why is because it's a warehouse for
black men in this country for
non-violent crimes right you [__]
idiot there's a reason why that idea
exists because you exist Ron DeSantis if
you didn't exist in in our power
structure we wouldn't have to talk about
if decent people decent human beings had
control over policy all across the
country in our governments not just the
federal government but the state the
county the school boards if decent
people across the board were in charge
of that power and those policies we
there wouldn't be the situation that
we're in but that is not our history
that is what we're trying to [__]
tell you is that's not our history so
why are you trying to teach something
that is not our history our history is a
white male power structure that that has
oppressed marginalized communities in
this country and you are afraid to not
only tell white people that but you are
deadly afraid to tell black people and
lgbtq people that they have been
marginalized by the same white male
institution
[__] piece of garbage and to tell
black people what the [__] they want are
you [__] me
tell them what the hell they want you
piece of trash you want to know you want
to know and I'm sure a lot of people
don't know this
um unless you're from the Louisiana area
you want to know how [__] up the
prison system is I oh go ahead hi so
there's there's something that's called
so at the end go Angola prison okay
there's something that's called the
Angola prison uh Rodeo okay
and they hold these different events so
you've got a bunch of inmates who are uh
who are good behaving inmates right
they're given an opportunity it's an
incentive keep in mind the words I'm
using it's an incentive and for to be
rewarded for their good behavior they
can earn money and and things like that
okay not much but they can earn money
they have these
really [__] up events one of them that
is insanely [__] up and keep in mind
this is a bunch of Spectators a bunch of
people are there at this rodeo and
they're watching they've got something
and this is one event this is just one
there's like I don't know six seven or
so
it's called Uh bull poker okay
and or sorry convict poker is that
excellent convict poker and they sit at
a table and there's four inmates they've
got a a chest guard and a helmet okay
and they're dealing cards and they're
playing poker and they've got uh the
rodeo clowns and other people that are
drawing the Bulls
to hit them the last one sitting at the
table that doesn't get knocked off their
chair our runaway or or run yeah or run
away uh are rewarded and they get you
know money and the stipend or whatever
into their account okay so just know
that this is something that still exists
to this day this is something that is so
incredibly [__] up and this is only
one state this is one state where they
play a game with people's lives keep in
mind you've got a [__] you know I
don't know how many tons of a bull
muscle two horns coming at you like a
[__] freight train knocks you off of
your chair God forbid you don't uh
[__] snap your neck you don't get a
[__] bull horn in your body or some
other injury that you you incur by being
some good behaving inmate that then
tries to benefit you know through these
rewards of playing a game of convict
poker again that is just one state and
this is called Angola prison radio Rodeo
if people want to look it up it's [__]
up there's a handful of games they play
with they're just playing with people's
lives
so when Ron DeSantis says oh it's just
political and the idea that we're
pushing this this uh this you know
dissolvement of the prison systems and
whatever there's [__] Merit for it
well [__] Merit for the treatment
especially for uh uh uh people who were
gone were put in prison for for trivial
crimes oh he had a small amount of
marijuana or anything else or whatever
and I know what Rhonda Santos is doing
here with the abolishment of Prisons the
abolishment of private run prisons right
is what the abolishment that people are
calling for which is what we should call
for in this country because our policy
our policy our government it's us we are
the government should control the policy
of the prison system in this country
because I mean everyone knows that you
can't not have a prison system right you
know that we know the facts but we do
not we do not have to put up with a
private prison system that is designed
for profit now we've seen time and time
again one particular instance where a
judge I think it was last year the year
before and
um and the Name Escapes me where the
judge was tried and convicted on federal
charges of racketeering little juvenile
children to put them in the juvenile
centers because him and his buddy who
own the juvenile system and the juvenile
center were buddies and they were he was
paying him Kickbacks children he was
putting in the juvenile system so spare
me the [__] they're gonna it's a
political move to abolish prisons no
what people are calling for and should
be calling for in this country is
prisons for profit you [__] right and
also I mean it in slave labor right the
idea that you can use inmates as a way
to rehabilitate
through free or low wage labor that
private companies get to benefit you
know and that is what is going on here
is is also the idea that like oh God
forbid my buddies don't get the money
and they don't hit their quota for the
year and they don't get their you know
their bonuses for making sure that they
hit some uh project goal by uh by taking
advantage of people who were in prison
for you know probably non-violent
committing offenses
but [__] it uh they're there so we might
as well use them and that's something
else too that is something else that
they don't want people to know this idea
that oh there's actually a large
percentage of African-Americans
incarcerated in prisons and we use those
people to actually uh
you know [__] perform slave labor
right and there's controls and
corporations that profit off of it God
forbid somebody would be like hey we
probably shouldn't do that and also we
probably shouldn't do that to like I you
know if someone was in that Community
they would say I take offense of this
because that is my fellow Community
member and they're being treated in a
way that doesn't regard them as a human
being
but then but it's it it is disgusting
that Rhonda Santos is telling telling
black people what the the white man
in Florida the Florida Hitler is telling
black people what they want let's finish
this up and then we're we'll move on to
the uh the classroom book burning that
he wants to do so that is more of
ideology being used under the guise of
history and we want to do uh history and
that's what our standards for for black
history are it's just cut and dried
history you learn all the basics you
learn about the great figures and you
know I view it as American history I
don't view it as separate history you
know we have history a lot of different
shapes and sizes people that have
participated uh to make the country
great uh people that have stood up when
it wasn't easy and they all deserve uh
uh to be taught but abolishing prisons
being taught to high school kids is if
that's somehow a fact no that that's
that's not appropriate listen he doesn't
want you to know the facts these private
prisons that's that's what he doesn't
want you to know he does not want you to
know and he definitely definitely does
not want black folks to know the the
[__] history of private privatization
of Prisons definitely doesn't want you
to know if he potentially has any sort
of I don't know uh investment in private
prisons I don't know I'm not sure I'm
not saying he does right because I don't
know but God forbid it wouldn't be uh I
don't know wouldn't be unusual you
wouldn't be surprised yeah
unsurprisingly Ron DeSantis probably has
some sort of tangential connection to
these prisons right right and he's he's
like oh I'm I'm triggered by the way
that you would want to take away this
business model of exploitation
well uh the next thing I want to move on
to because
um and then we're going to go to
back to the wokism thing because it's
all connected this this I know it sounds
crazy Abe Sanchez but the Eminem thing
this is Rhonda santis Banning Banning
the ability for people who want to
college prep to go to a course to learn
the facts about privatization of prisons
and how it's changed the dichotomy of of
incarcerated people in this country
affecting marginalized groups I don't
know like African Americans
you would and he doesn't want you to
know that it's the same thing it's it's
the exact same thing yeah as the Eminem
story I know that sounds crazy I know
it's like whoa that sounds that sounds
nuts but it's the same drip drip drip
and that's how they do this and there's
an Xbox story that I want to show you
but first
I'm dead serious no no I know I I know
okay oh yeah I know what it is yeah yeah
I know what it is and as someone who is
an Xbox a former Xbox owner years ago
right it is not new well and and this is
the whole gastos M M's Xbox thing yeah
but folks they do these little bitty
things to get these people all [__]
worked up so that way when they present
them with hey they're teaching queer
Theory and the abolishment of prisons in
this course and we just can't have that
and black people don't want that either
black people hey black people you don't
want that wink wink because if they show
you hey they're taking away your gas
stoves and they're trying to
indoctrinate your children with a bunch
of candy that we have sexualized for
years on Fox news right and we've we're
in and oh no they're trying to change
your Xbox and make it a why buy some
[__] I'm sure they would say they're
like it's going from X to Y and that's a
y box and they're trying to make it all
[__] uh estrogen filled does the Xbox
have a have a have a wiener or a vagina
which yeah like I think that they're
like okay are they gonna go to the
gender thing I think they're gonna be
like oh the x is oh hell yeah they're
gonna be like oh yeah and they're like
oh yeah and estrogen fill that's what it
is that's what it is and we'll we'll get
to that story here in a minute because
only real men use all of the energy well
that that's true that's true and and uh
um Judd has the story here I mean this
is a big thread on it and please read
the thread uh I've retweeted it and I'll
I'll thank Judd here but
um Florida teachers are being told to
remove all books from their classroom
libraries or face felony prosecution
this is real now the new policy is based
on the premise the teachers are using
books to groom students and indoctrinate
them with leftist ideologies okay so we
know we know that the far right wing nut
jobs have banned books that they don't
want children to know facts about the
same way that Rhonda santis doesn't want
black folks to to know facts about the
private station in the prison system in
this country and how the the plight of
marginalized groups is the plight of all
marginalized groups in the fight for
equality and Equity is all tied together
in our country's history he doesn't want
you to know that he also he also doesn't
want kids to read Dr Seuss anymore right
um and he definitely doesn't want them
to learn how to read with reading levels
yeah because what happens in these
schools
and I don't I don't I I know you don't
have but I have it kids and they went to
schools we sent them the schools that's
what we did they go to public schools
and generally speaking public schools in
most red States especially a red State
like Missouri they're [__] broke and
the reason why they're [__] broke is
because people like Ron DeSantis and
other Republicans do not see the value
or like you said earlier the investment
in education so they strip it of all the
funding so that way I don't know
libraries not only do they do they not
have many books but there's the
possibility that they won't have the
books that the Republicans don't want
students to read yeah so what happens is
is these teachers they have to develop
their own little private libraries
inside their classrooms to teach
students how to read because the library
just does not produce enough books for
those students and have the availability
of those books for those students I
don't know to educate them yeah what
they do is the teachers and and my wife
even I have have given and donated
several books as our children get older
we donate them down to classrooms that
can use them to educate students because
they need they desperately need books uh
especially when they pack these
classrooms for a 25 35 students they
desperately need more and more material
to teach these students how to read
that's what the um Gabe I don't know if
you know this but that's what children's
books are designed to do in most cases
are designed to get them to um what's
the word read oh because you know let me
tell you something let me tell you a
unique idea here and maybe I'm just
coming up with it maybe this is
something that no one's ever heard
before but if you can read Gabe Sanchez
if you can read and you're a really good
reader especially if you start young you
don't learn to read I don't know in like
kindergarten and then and then the
teachers work hard to get you through
those levels to make sure I don't know
you're reading at a normal level that
you would be at your age in your
development
I would bet that studies would show if
we did studies and I'm sure there's none
out there from this I'm sure of it that
that if we show that people and adults
who know how to read on a certain level
have an easier time learning something
and disseminating facts from fiction I
almost bet I almost bet there's there
there should be studies out there that
show that that if that if a person can
read
at a certain level in their development
that they can actually I don't know
learn things and disseminate fact from
fiction it's almost as if Ronda santis
does not want children to know how to
read and not read on a certain level
here it's almost like he's grooming to
make a DeSantis youth in Florida I don't
know I'm just well yeah I mean like if
you were you know again if you stop the
flow of knowledge and learning and and
even and more so right the idea that you
would prevent people in in high school
learning something that is a you know
it's a complex topic right there's a lot
of [__] that happened and you probably
won't be able to cover it all even in an
AP course but the idea that he's trying
to cut off the air supply right of this
of this course
because he's afraid that if he allows it
to happen
then those people who are of sound mind
and body and adults right 17 18 year
olds are able to then go out and have
these conversations right and they have
conversations in their families and
maybe there's a younger person in that
household who learns about these things
about African-American history and and
what what happened during the
development of the country from the
beginning to now right
um he doesn't want that he doesn't want
the
the uh the potential of somebody
eavesdropping and hearing some topic and
then that person going wait hold on what
was that and then they go and they go to
the library and they look it up and they
educate themselves as a as a younger
person you know in grade school and say
oh my God that is really you know messed
up as a kid uh and then they go I have I
now have an interest to learn more and I
want to self-educate and learn and read
and you know obviously like whoa whoa
whoa whoa you're really marching
together you know you're jumping you're
jumping from the you know Berenstein
Bears over to the the history of our
country you're really you're really
you're really starting to uh talk about
how how adults actually get educated I'm
just saying learning is addictive
and if you and if it's interesting
enough then you'll want to do it
yourself
and this whole like Joseph Goebbels type
[__] that that DeSantis is trying to
do where he's probably burning these
books and laughing like a [__] Maniac
in the in the near the dumpster in the
back of the school
is only going to make certain people
want to say why are you doing that and
also
now I'm more inclined it's like when you
try to ban alcohol or or drugs you know
before you allow them to be recreational
you're going to create more of an
incentive for people to be like oh well
now I want to see what all the [__]
hoopla is about like why are you trying
to get rid of it well the other thing
that you do too and um this is by Design
and you you went through the Dare
program in school right this garbage
program that teaches children that
marijuana is the same the same as heroin
or Methamphetamine which is totally
[__] or or they most dangerous
narrative that they ever spun to us in
the just say no [__] using false
studies as well yeah but but I mean the
the pure fact that they say oh yeah you
know I they used to bring in like this
case it was like a glass front and they
had all the drugs in it right yeah and
they were they were pointing out the
drugs and they're like marijuana is just
as bad as heroin so like you have this
situation where you know you get a
teenage kid kid who learned this stupid
[__] three years before in Dare class
that marijuana is the exact same as
heroin doesn't know you know their ass
from a hole in the ground because
they're 14 years old 15 years old in
high school and someone they're smoking
weed and then someone offers them heroin
like well you know the cotton the cop
said the DARE officer said it's the
exact same right the marijuana doesn't
[__] me up that bad I'm not dead so I
mean and or Methamphetamine or whatever
it is whatever dangerous uh illicit drug
that that a person should take very very
wide caution and I'm not discouraging
drug use hell and you're an adult when
you're a grown ass adult
you know and you want to do drugs hey
I'm I'm pro-choice baby you you choose
you know go ahead it's your [__] body
your choice do the drugs you want I mean
you can't put other people in danger I
mean I'm against that but if you want to
sit at your house
and smoke methamphetamine hey buddy that
you know whatever I'm who am I to say
who the [__] am I to say you're not
having fun what am I what am I to do but
here's the thing
is that this is the same stupid [__]
when they're saying this book is bad
because it has words that we don't like
and an order that we don't like so all
books all books and this is the this is
the uh the quote you're unvetted books
unvetted so all books that aren't that
aren't approved by Rhonda santis are all
bad yeah
no one is when they say you know
unvetted there is I guarantee it no one
in their Department of Education or
whoever is in is is in their little
depressing uh basement Room reading
these books no one is actually vetting
these books no one is actually reading
them I guarantee if anything they're
getting second-hand information from
someone else that says oh it mentioned
this the same reason that Florida banned
books math books because it literally
had the word theory in it because
they're like oh critical race Theory can
I push back on you a little bit there
yeah there are people who who vet these
books they're children's book publishers
who vet these books yeah okay I I don't
I don't understand
why why anyway and and corporations
aren't perfect right they have a profit
model
um and because there's the profit Model
A lot of times they'll do things that
aren't in the interest of the end user
that's more in the interest of the
corporation so I understand that I I get
it I understand it but what you also
have to understand is there's a huge
infrastructure that we have
intentionally built in this country of
public education and public school
teachers and then and this is why unions
are important by the way but we're not
going to get into that conversation but
there's an entire infrastructure here
that is designed and and mandated by the
way mandated by the government to make
sure our citizens and the people in this
country who reside here are educated
there's an entire centuries
of infrastructure that has been built
around this to make sure these books are
quote vetted but what this means
unvetted in the quote is that they don't
like the words that are put in the book
in the order that they're put in the
book because somehow that might convince
someone of the truth and Lisa is right
here from Facebook she says reading
leads to critical thinking skills and
they [__] definitely don't want that
[__] especially Ron DeSantis and
especially they do not want black folks
to have critical thinking skills that's
his goal here it's critical critical
sounds like critical race Theory so it
doesn't sound good to me does critical
thinking critical yeah man that's really
that's really cool if you throw an r in
there and you're right you're right
there you're right there aren't you holy
moly in a critical reality thinking I
don't know boy that boy I don't want to
piss off free slope man I don't want to
piss off the right wing nut job you're
gonna have some people from Florida's
Department of Education kicking down
your door [__] them let them come come
and get me [__] come and get me come
and get me I hear Stephen King the Tweet
we were talking about earlier this is
from a few days ago and this is the one
I saw I think it I think um this in any
parents tool chest this should be
exactly the tool that you would use if
someone's telling uh your student or
your children
um not to read something he says hey
kids it's your old buddy Stephen King
telling you that if they ban a book in
your school haul your ass to the nearest
bookstore Library ASAP and find out what
they don't want you to read because it's
important the [__] they don't want you
to read that's the important stuff
that's the important stuff that they
don't want you to read
um Barnes and Noble actually had a tweet
on this can you see if you can find the
Barnes yeah Barnes Noble
still you know huh
I I there's a few stores I guess there's
one there's one not too far from the one
in our town shut down but at the Town
not too far from me there's actually a
store but I think it's it's mainly
online now they almost do business and
they still exist or just you know
digital virtual well I mean I mean you
know with the uh with the um invention
what was the sir what was the topic it
was just uh books but I think they talk
about oh oh you got it yeah I got it
right here I got it right here yeah yeah
yeah
um I'm gonna retweet this I mean it's
pretty I would say it's pretty on the
nose I I mean uh there's several
corporations that have really good
accounts I think Wendy's is a really
good one uh oh yeah yeah Arby's has a
really cool there was a big um in like
2017 2018 all of these all of these
accounts became like um
uh like kind of transient in a way uh
and and they
were having the they just became P they
be essentially became people right they
these companies had
uh whether they had a um
uh like a
a character or not they were
um
they had attitude they had sass they had
uh sarcasm they had you know well they
were trying they were trying to build
followings they were trying to get
attention it's marketing like we were
talking about yesterday with the [__]
imminents we talked about it for an hour
and a half about how the whole scheme is
to bait the right wing into getting
people like us and everyone else to talk
about [__] M Ms uh but here's Barnes
Noble now I think they messed this up
just a bit Gabe Sanchez and maybe maybe
won't
um I think they could have changed just
a one thing about this tweet that would
have
um got it more viral than it did uh it's
a this is Barnes and Noble and this is
from their Buzz account being BN Buzz
um so this is like one of their official
accounts right
um it says Banning book seems pretty
suspect and they should have said you
know what I'm gonna say right they
should have said sus right yeah they
should have appealed because they should
have said sus they should appealed to
the people who
um Rhonda Santos is trying to take the
books away from I in my in my opinion in
my opinion here I'm not saying it's a
bad tweet I'm just saying it could have
been better if they just would have
taken out a few letters is all I'm
saying what do you think yeah yeah am I
on my rocker nope nope nope this is
marketing so I mean I'm trying to I
think on the sh on the show one day I
said uh I was like I don't know this
seems pretty sus and then somebody in
the comments was like don't say suss
it's the kids and I'm like well yeah
well you know listen listen rather you
want to uh adhere to the young young
youngins language or not Banning books
is pretty [__] sus oh it's pretty
it's pretty [__] sucks pretty [__]
says dancing why are you trying this
here's the thing yeah that oh that's
suspicious that's weird that's weird
because here's the thing it's like why
are you trying to ban books like what is
in the book that makes you so upset that
you want to get rid of it and it's only
going to make people more interested
right you're gonna be like oh hold on
just like I said just like I said with
the with the marijuana heroin thing
right yeah when you lie to him and you
tell them that [__] they get they get
humans are curious especially young
humans I don't know if you met a [__]
adolescent they're curious as [__] about
stuff yeah curious as [__] humans are
curious yeah oh that's crazy yeah I
don't I don't that's it's almost like
that's a it's like a natural state and
you should you should foster that by
allowing them to learn certain things so
they go oh okay I know better for next
time or wow that's really [__] up I'm
glad I learned that now I have a better
idea of what a certain group I don't
know an African-American Community might
have gone through during a certain time
imagine if you had an open mind imagine
oh my God the things that the things
that we could accomplished yeah with an
open mind oh my God ah we can't do that
not in this country not in this country
we have people complaining about M M's
and Xboxes
um being woke I'm not [__] you this
is [__] crazy here oh boy this is
from uh of course Fox News Fox and
Friends this morning
[Music]
um
they're talk of course we have on the
screen you know you know who this is
this is the new mother woker that will
that will um uh be the spokeswoker of
the woke candy Mars Eminem line because
they got rid of the cartoon wokers
because again you know we've got a
Jewish biracial
uh comedian who's female and she's also
a feminist Oh I thought well I thought
you were I thought you were describing
someone else but uh you're describing
her you're describing yeah I'm
describing her I'm describing The
Talented Maya Rudolph and saying how I
still can't get over the fact and here's
the thing I'm doing a what was that on
this and I'm gonna call it [__] I'm I
call out the left about this whole like
hey totally [__] it up yesterday they
totally [__] it up Eminem
played the right perfectly yeah but they
didn't get the left they didn't do it
the left took it at face value right and
didn't read the subtext didn't read the
tone yesterday why it was parody didn't
look at the fact that the characters are
on the [__] announcement right we're
so controversial and woke well as soon
as I saw it I I knew that and then I and
that's the reason why I sent it to you
the immediately after I read it right I
sent it to you and I think I actually
said um
in the text I said um
I think I said oh they [__] some
people up or something like that like oh
this is totally gonna throw a wrenches
yeah the comments like oh my God I'm
gonna so like the what was that I'm
doing makes fun of and these are friends
of ours these are friends
let's call what it is right uh you guys
got [__] dude you took it at face
value you didn't read it
what happened was I'm sure a lot of
people saw other people freaking out
because they misread it and became a
game of telephone right and they were
like oh no well because caved to Tucker
Carlson no they did not well that's that
and Tucker Carlson took the bait last
night
out of the [__] Candy's hand man so
did Nick Adams he took the bait
yesterday he even did a video where he
didn't even have his [__] pants on he
did a Mike Lindell and he did a video
without his pants
um so here's the little clip from uh Fox
and Friends this morning telling us why
we should believe that Xbox is woke just
like Eminem's and I'm gonna tell you why
this is really [__] stupid
um let's listen because my son has an
Xbox has had several of them but listen
so Xbox has also announced they're going
woke too and you know because of climate
change that they're adding a new feature
to their default settings so if you own
an Xbox you can upload this new program
and it will turn off after so long to
save the environment the power and also
they're saying the energy saving
shutdown feature is going to have a
slower boot time Ted Cruz writes on
Twitter first gas stoves then your
coffee now you're gunning for my Xbox
because Ted Cruz is the one we look to
yeah the guy who ran away to Cancun
while the the state went into absolute
chaos no apocalypse and then when he was
caught he blamed his daughters for being
a good parent you're telling me that one
parent can't take two girls down to
Cancun on her own on a flight in in yeah
you tell me that I don't think so nobody
needs you around [__] Ted nobody
needs you around now your family not
your daughters not your constituents
nobody [__] needs them because he's
absolutely useless you know what's funny
about this Xbox story
number one all every listen to me when I
tell you this and I don't game at all at
all yeah and I know that every single
electronic that they develop one of the
one of the features that they put at the
top of the list is that it doesn't run
up your electric bill yeah you stupid
[__] idiots Xbox has had this feature
on their consoles for years so is
PlayStation so is everything I've got a
PS4 that I think now is like I don't
know six seven years old they have
energy saving yes all of them have to
keep it on I can't keep it on if I
wanted the same way that these my very
computer will say after a certain amount
of time it goes please I go to sleep and
the reason why isn't because of I mean
climate change it's because you pay for
you to you pay for you pay for do you
pay for your electricity or does George
Soros give it to you Gabe Sanchez which
is it Jesus Christ how can they not
understand that the [__] that you have
on in your house runs your bill up and
it might be a good idea when you're
buying Electronics since we have so many
of them these days that you you consider
the ones with the features that would go
to sleep so I don't know it doesn't run
up your [__] electric you people it's
so much and moan about the electric bill
about the gas those about the fuel
prices and you don't even understand
that companies out there are making
products that people want to buy so
their electric bills aren't [__] high
you boneheads this is nothing to do with
wokeism I wonder uh because I know that
we still have the the Mike penstock
stuff to discuss but oh okay yeah yeah
yeah yeah
you know here here's a segue
I would I would believe that some of
these people these Republicans who want
to [__] and moan about the energy
saving feature the rest mode that's on a
[__] console
to make sure hey maybe we shouldn't burn
it because here's the thing when that I
mean just like a computer like that
thing's running the thing gets hot man
you could do damn like constantly
spinning that disc it can cause damage
it may be no right now Gabe Sanchez what
Xbox do you own what version do you own
I don't know I have a PS4 oh well you
know that Xboxes don't have disc in them
anymore you know that right I know but
Xbox Xbox 360 was the last one right I'm
just trying I'm just trying to make sure
I know you're not that you're not you're
not showing your age here yeah at all
yeah I think the last one was Xbox 360.
but I switched over to PS4 and that's
the one that I have now wow I don't even
game as much as I should I bought this
thing and I like I don't game as much as
I should but I don't game at all but but
the idea here what I say is and this is
my segue into into Mike Pence
the same people who want to [__] and
moan about this energy cost saving [__]
are probably the same people who plug in
their Christmas lights or their outdoor
lights and set them up to a Goddamn
timer so that people know oh someone is
home it's seven o'clock look the lights
are on somebody must be home right and
in that same way right I would guarantee
that somebody like Mike Pence also does
that to his home in Indiana
oh Desi why why would he do that to his
home in Indiana is there something
inside his home in Indiana I'm just
saying he probably wants people to know
that he's there
so that people don't come into his house
and maybe I don't know burglarize or try
to take something and maybe that's
something is classified documents from
his time wait a second wait a second
wait a second that is not the story that
is not the story the story that we're
supposed to say is that Joe Biden and
Hunter Biden's laptop
intentionally placed class top secret
classified documents inside of his
Corvette and he drove around with
hookers and they gave hookers yeah not
only blow but also the top secret
classified documents that's the story
we're supposed to go with that is the
truth that is the story juvenile that's
the Q Anon truth here what is this that
you say about Mike Pence and his
documents well it was revealed today you
know breaking news but it was you know
last week over the weekend kind of uh as
it developed uh there were a a s they
said you know just like just like Joe
Biden a small number of documents were
discovered in the personal home of
former vice president president Mike
Pence Deanna whoa whoa that is the wrong
vice president that's the wrong one that
you're supposed to is it the wrong one I
don't know uh here's a clip from Ace and
um
from CNN when is this from uh this is
from today probably is it from today
yeah the news broke to this morning okay
while we're on the show this is Mike
this is Mike Pence saying he definitely
does not uh no even he didn't he never
seen one before in his life you've never
seen the classified he never he doesn't
know who this is my document person is
definitely a coffee boy for sure I I
have my money is on mother stealing the
documents but the fly snitching on him
oh it's all the Flies fault let's watch
did you take any classified documents
with you from the White House
uh I I did not oh
so so this interview is from ABC
um it is from November 14 2022 and he
said in an interview he did not take
them so I bet I would almost bet that
the follow-up here is going to be that
he didn't take any documents yeah I
would say that's the story yeah you said
back in November 2022 he said he didn't
take any and now today they're finding
out that he didn't actually no I guess
he did you see any reason for anyone to
take classified documents with them
leaving the White House
well there'd be no reason to have
classified documents particularly if
they were in an unprotected area
well there were classified documents and
they were in as you report an
unprotected area
[Music]
this is when this is what they get me
wrong every time part of your enthusiasm
outro
[Music]
yeah oh my God
um these chuckleheads you know what you
know what you know what's great about
this you know what's great about this
is that
hey hey folks the problem isn't
that bike pants may or may not have them
Joe Biden May or not have them that
Donald Trump May or not have them one of
the biggest issues with I'm sure the
Pence case and the the Biden case is how
classified documents become classified
and unclassified and reclassified in the
first place it's one of the things but
until we have actual level heads in
Washington that policy is way far from
where we're even going to get to at this
point but the difference between the
Mike Pence documents in his home and the
Joe Biden documents in his home which
I'm sure because I actually don't know
of any at this point any Criminal Intent
that Mike Pence would have nor Joe Biden
and I wouldn't be surprised if Mike
Pence honestly
didn't know that he had those documents
who knows we don't know yet we don't
know we just simply know that he does
have them even though he said he didn't
right right just like Joe Biden now
jimin
but we what we do know because Donald
Trump's big [__] mouth and because he
always projects his crimes we know
that he had intent on stealing those
documents what his intent was more than
likely and that he obstructed when when
ordered to give those documents back
so much so that a federal judge was
willing to sign a bench warrant for for
a search and seizure of those documents
based on three criminal statutes which
has not happened in the Mike Pence case
or the Joe Biden case so are these are
these cases the same absolutely [__]
not the only thing that ties these cases
together at all is that our
classification system of documents kind
of sucks in this country yeah and the
custody of these classified documents
kind of sucks in this country and we
really need to evaluate it but uh folks
honestly
do you want this House of
Representatives trying to pass
legislation on [__] re on a
classification classification of our of
our secrets that we have to protect our
security in this nation not only that
but the custody you want Matt Gatson Jim
Jordan and Marjorie Taylor green helping
decide how the custody and the
classification system works for our top
secret information [__] no hails to the
no you do not want that so this idea
that we're going to pass some kind of
classified documents reform people need
to shut the hell up about that because
that's not even in the cards at this
point we will be lucky to raise the debt
ceiling which is an automatic thing to
not [__] default on our debt and be
lucky to keep the government open so we
can keep running in this country we'll
be lucky to do those two things this
year at a bare minimum bare minimum
forget about any kind of legislation
that's going to fundamentally change
and push forward our country to make it
better Republicans don't make our
country better folks they want to make
it worse that's their goal it's actually
a feature of their party it's actually a
feature so
um what else do we know since this is
just breaking what else do we know about
this because I I I don't know a lot
about this um
that's kind of where it's at right now
um it you know it happened last week
slash over the weekend that the
documents were discovered and then
it was just revealed today so I would I
would imagine that this comes um with
the uh news uh that Biden had these
documents and probably the facts that we
don't know as the public of how those
documents ended up in Joe Biden's house
I'm sure they're
um the department Justice and Nara are
um looking into other vice presidents of
how that would happen as well because it
was probably inadvert inadvertent and um
you know not I wouldn't say accidental
because I think that's a wrong word here
um but because words matter and I think
accidental is is wrong
no so from what I read uh Pence engage
with outside counsel with experience in
handling classified documents to review
records stored in this personal home
after it became uh public knowledge that
there were documents in Joe Biden's
Wilmington Delaware home so he was like
oh [__] just in case I should probably
and I'm sure the reason why Mike Pence
did this because is this is the this is
the reporting via CNN from Hugo here a
lawyer for former Mike or excuse me
former vice president Mike Pence
discovered about a dozen documents
marked as classified at Pence's Indiana
home last week and he has turned those
classified documents over to the FBI
that sounds familiar uh in this Grand
stream of scheme of why these stories
aren't aren't the same apples
apples meaning Biden Pence and orange
yeah the uh Cheeto dust Q anoner down at
Mar-A-Lago
um because we know that intent and
obstruction is the actual case
that's the three [__] criminal
statutes that the judge used to issue
the [__] bench warrant for a search
and seizure of those documents were
three statues his intent and his
obstruction that is the difference folks
when you when you steal lie hide and
then use your lawyers to and other
people to uh to move documents around a
different storage facilities and areas
and then try to do that over 18 months
and play in this like cat and mouse game
with Nara and the FBI
you don't have any ground to stand on to
say oh hey oops uh my bad this is a
mistake didn't mean it
here you go here are the documents
um feel free to sweep my house and look
for the stuff just want to make sure
that I I that you got it all but I just
wanted to come to you ahead of time and
let you know that I I took these by
accident uh they got packed up in a box
you know how things go and then they
would say no problem we'll do a sweep
we'll look for we found the documents
thanks so much for being helpful and
Cooperative you never heard any of that
during the Trump search because that's
the the final straw was they're like
[__] man this guy's
he lies to us he tells he doesn't have
them we have to go in and find this [__]
because we have to do it ourselves the
other thing I want to point out too here
in the Mike Pence case because we don't
have a lot of reporting on it yet but
also the Joe Biden case is that these
documents maybe Mark classified but that
does not mean they are
um we found this out in the Hillary
Clinton email Scandal when there was a
couple emails that were marked
classified but they were that the
information and the damn email was
reclassified and it wasn't it wouldn't
have any markings so that's one problem
that we have with our system is the
classification reclassification how the
custody of this information moves around
especially in the executive branch
because it has to move a lot faster in
the executive branch because they have
to act faster than like Congress or the
Senate
um speaking of the uh Cheeto dust Q
anoner freaking out
um he's freaking out a little about
something a little different here Gabe
Sanchez this might be some of the stuff
that he destroyed in those classified
voters to cover up this this here
because he's freaking out this morning
Aaron as well as several other people
and posted the screenshot from True
social but I'm going to show his here
his tweet uh Trump on true social on his
call asking the Georgia AG to find
enough votes for him to beat Biden and
we know this if you could just find me
if you just find me 11 780 roots
okay um and quote I won the George
Georgia by a lot
but only needed a small number of votes
he wanted by a lot but he still needed
votes right I wouldn't buy a lot but I
still need to votes right just find me
the guy what was the line he goes
um
uh on that phone call yeah he was like
he was like come on I'm just I right
hold on hold on I I'll find it yeah
please find him in a box it was one
there was one line he said to Brad
raffensberger uh on the phone that
wasn't it was outside of the I need this
many uh
I just want your legs to be okay is that
what he said oh that's something pretty
much I just want your legs to be okay
okay so I'm gonna read this while you're
finding that yeah yeah this is his
statement on uh fraud social this
morning about the uh uh what looks like
the oh yeah
of the testimony yeah go ahead he said
he said give me a break he goes I just
need 11 000 votes guys give me a break
okay wait wait there's a there give me a
break give me a break break me off a
piece of that kit kit or can we not eat
kitkats anymore are they woke too I
don't know it depends on which side you
break up yeah I guess I guess it could
be woke up
then you're in a Twix territory oh my
God Jesus this woke isn't we really got
to get this pen down okay
um he starts this [__] post off again
with page one I don't know why he's
doing this I told you he's doing it
because he's trying to make this his own
with her files because then yeah his own
Twitter files he's making it seem
important and then that way you look
looking to go oh how many pages there's
the fact that he even had page one means
as a page two and they're probably just
page three which means it's probably
page 57. I can't wait for this [__]
chucklehead to get back on Twitter I
really can't honestly people are like no
and I'm like yeah let's get him back on
Twitter I'm excited to see what his
first tweet back is because I know they
said that they're brainstorming oh I
know what his first tweet is gonna be
100 make America great again oh again or
make Twitter great again one or the
other guarantee it write it down [__]
time stamp this Tuesday January 24th
uh uh 159
p.m eastern time Tony Michaels says it's
going to be one of two things make
America great again or make Twitter
great again exclamation point I'm just
going Asian point
Hunter Biden's dick he's just gonna post
a dick pic yeah of Hunter Biden's huge
hog
because why didn't he give this to the
doj now yeah right okay so yeah let me
read the uh the fraud social uh post
here
because he's terrified of this grand
jury uh testimony leaking apparently he
says page one my phone call to the
Secretary of State of Georgia and the
second call which the Marxist communist
racist and rhinos oh my God oh my God
he's calling out all his enemies there
yeah if you're not catching it because
they're the racists are against him
um okay yeah all right good story
grandpa
um don't even want to talk about where
were perfect again calls we've heard
this before sometime in his history what
was the other perfect phone call is that
the one where he was trying to extort
the president of Ukraine yeah it was
totally normal perfect phone call
nothing illegal about it
yeah
it goes he goes on the puke up many
people including lawyers for both sides
yeah you heard that [__] before too hey
there's great people on both sides we're
knowingly on the line
so so Gabe Sanchez you cannot commit
crime on the phone if there's if there's
lawyers on the phone it's not a thing
you just can't do it as long as lawyers
are on the phone it's not crime
apparently uh a very unknown uh well
documented but it's it's just like from
years great defense yeah that says like
if they're on the phone get out of here
totally fine I'm sure the lawyers on the
burn like oh my God you just broke the
law you just broke the law you might not
know this but this is actually a Florida
or this is a Georgia law oh okay if you
go to the local County Courthouse in in
uh in Atlanta Georgia you can actually
read it oh really yeah yeah but but
honestly they're trying to walk you're
from Florida if you're from Florida you
might not be they're trying to destroy
it because they don't want people to
learn right but it's actually there is a
law that says if a lawyer's on the phone
it's not illegal and and you're totally
you totally have passed the bar in
Georgia and know this for yeah and I'm
and I'm I'm about to take the bar in
Florida too are you from Brazil I'm just
I'm just asking questions does your mom
was your mom at 9 11 or in Brazil which
which is it yes okay uh I think people
are knowing where we're going with that
one
um he goes on to say I was protesting a
rigged and stolen election which is
completely false he knew that he knew
that he had lost uh they've proven
proven that uh through the January 6th
Select Committee in December which was
before this perfect phone call that he
claims which evidence prove it was I won
Georgia by a lot again another lie not
surprising but only needed a small
number of votes from the total number
they cheated in many ways including
stuffing ballots all caught live on tape
and I'm sure he's talking about 2 000
mules and he's talking about um the
election workers that he's been
harassing uh since since the election
it's um this is hilarious by the way
this is almost almost not quite almost
better than his [__] shitty diaper
rant about the [__] empty folders
because he's telling he's telling you
exactly what the report and the
testimony is going to show the testimony
is going to show that the lawyers that
were on the phone thought he did
something illegal in that moment and we
know rathisburger's [__] lawyers
believe that the other side and his
lawyers believe that because Eric
Hershman has said as much in the [__]
testimony of January 6. so this
testimony is gonna show that the lawyers
that were on the phone in the moment
they were like whoa you can't do that
that's illegal yeah the other thing that
this testimony is going to show
the other thing that this testimony is
going to show is that that Marx's
communist racist rhinos because I know
why he's saying rhinos don't want to
talk about it is because everyone that
was on this phone call every
[__] one of them
all Republicans
all of them all the people that were on
this phone call
Republicans not marxists not communists
definitely probably racist definitely
because probably most likely absolutely
racist right rhinos I don't know what
even that means anymore I don't think
they know what that means so maybe
possibly but also I I want I want to
tell you that this testimony is going to
show
that he absolutely knew that he had lost
and he knows that he did not have the
number of votes to win in Georgia he had
lost Georgia and he knows that there is
no stuffing of ballots they told him
that with facts and evidence yeah and he
still he still would not give up on the
fact that he needed to commit crime to
steal our election to steal George's
election to to be install himself as a
dictator and King and that was the coup
attempt that's the entire [__] story
here and he's telling on himself right
in this statement I know exactly when
this drops if the testimony drops in the
grand jury I know exactly what it isn't
it supposed to drop wasn't today
supposed to be the day I think so that's
why he's freaking out again he's telling
he's telling his support he always does
this because he knows the crime that
he's committed well you got to get out
in front of it and make it sounded well
no he's not getting out in front of it
he's telling his supporters what to say
when the information drops
he's telling them what to say is what
he's doing and and and by telling them
what to say he's telling you what the
information is going to contain right I
mean that's why that's why he did the
whole classified empty folders things oh
they were keepsakes that's what they're
that's what they're ordered to say his
cult is ordered to say that there
keepsakes even though that's not even
close to what it is so uh we'll keep an
eye on this story also the uh the Mike
Pence document story as well as
completely [__] ignore the Biden
document story trust me that's what
we're gonna do because it's a no-nothing
it's a nothing Burger even Lindsey
Graham did you see this this morning
Lindsey Graham said Hey Joe Biden is not
going to mishandle uh classified
information that's a nothing Burger even
Lindsey Graham isn't playing politics
with this uh which only tells me for
sure that that if anyone barking up the
tree that Biden did something wrong here
or it's even close to the same as as
Donald Trump when he tried with his and
intent was to cover up a coup and his
obstruction of covering up a coup uh the
fact that Lindsey Graham is willing to
say this about uh Joe Biden and
acknowledge the fact that there is this
black and white scenario comparison but
then also be like wow I'll still support
the orange dude
that's a good point and maybe Lindsey
Graham knew about the information that
was going to drop about Mike Pence and
that's why Lindsey Graham's doing what
he's doing also because
um at this point they they have to pick
a lane that's right they've got to
decide what now the question is which um
which is the big question here does Mike
Pence get his own special counsel or
does the current special counsel looking
into the Biden case do they rope that
case in with it so
um I guess that's one one thing that
we'll be looking for in the news uh
based on the evidence that the doj gets
rather they they go ahead and appoint a
special counsel or let the current
special counsel looking into the Biden
documents because he was a vice
president and seems to be sort of that
same thing maybe they they put them so
we'll stay on it for you as well as you
should stay here stay tuned every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific we miss
Texas Paul today Tuesday I think he
might be back next week or the week
after I can't remember and I need to get
with him so anyone who missed Texas Paul
they don't no fear he will be back I'm
just not sure exactly when he's back
from vacation
um he deserves a vacation the guy
deserves it yeah he's been on the beach
I'm kind of jealous yeah honestly I
think following his posts he was like oh
listen he's idiots I tried I tried to
like some of them but you know I was
like you know what you bastard you're
out there having fun and doing all kinds
of good stuff I don't know that I'm
I mean I want you to have fun but I want
to have fun so right right I'm kind of
jealous he'll have some stories peanut
butter peanut butter and jelly over here
for sure for sure everyone everyone so
stay tuned uh tomorrow I'm sure we'll
have more on this uh Pence story
there'll be more uh leaking out through
the media uh through the evening and and
tomorrow morning so I know we'll have
that so everyone's stick around don't
don't don't hit the dial tomorrow at
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific be
right here on YouTube Twitter and twitch
don't forget to subscribe to the YouTube
channel super important we're trying to
get to 20 000 also download every single
episode on Apple Spotify Google and
download the Twitch app it's [__]
free it's free download to Twitch app
follow us over there it's free all of
it's free everything is free you can
watch us on YouTube for free
all of it's free free free free free
free to subscribe so please
um go to the Tony michaels.com and you
can find all the links there air to
follow us everywhere until tomorrow
same time same place same shitty diaper
I'm sure Surf's Up [__] you've
been listening to the Tony Michaels
podcast in your face commentary of
current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn hadass Beacon